you can buy them on amazon.com buy them on amazon this was not ultra by amazon.com
please click my affiliate that's great give up your dream jonathan don't don't
you're never going to become an amazon affiliate
all righty y'all time for another threat locker lockdown story okay picture this you're on an
internal pen test and you finally got a foothold on a target machine you've reached the point where
it's time to snoop around a little bit and see if you can find these little juicy pieces of
information that allow you to pivot deeper into the network you open up the desktop and what do
you see but what every hacker loves to see passwords.txt file you type cat or type or
whatever it is on windows to get the contents of that file and just as you press enter the shell
drops no why did the shell drop that my friend was a threat locker canary file and that machine is now
on complete lockdown you're burnt and scene i know i know i know that was traumatic you all but i had
to let you know what kind of things threat locker detect is doing to hackers so if you or a loved
hacker has experienced trauma at the hands of threat locker systems please call the threat locker hacker
complaint number at 833-292-7732 all right guys let's go back to the show all righty dr bowman the time
has come thank you for coming back on the pod man thanks thanks for the invite yeah i we we um i was
thinking you know i gotta have bowman on and i realized we actually did have you on in an episode
back in in the beginning of the podcast episode 17 um with all those all those hackers just kind of
sitting in a hotel room chatting about all the bug stories so that was definitely a great memory of mine
that's a good memory yeah it was just a some smallest hotel room all on the bench because there was not
more space there and yeah yeah i think i described some book that had me to create a music song and get
it released and all the hassle to get through to get it actually there where i wanted it to pop uh yeah
but it was a good time and i'm so honored that you guys still use it in the podcast yeah dude we use it
every episode i think people really like it at the end you know it's you know because you go through the
whole podcast the intro music is really like all right let's hype it up let's hype it up and then
at the end it's like okay now we're just gonna mellow it out right at the end right to be one of the
two like whitey cracker and me wow yeah standing in the credits next to whitey cracker come on it just
it just uh it adds to your list of achievements man which is which is where i wanted to start today
because it's like um i think you're probably one of the unique most unique hackers in our space you
know obviously bug bounty has a lot of a lot of um variants and the people that are participating in
it by nature of what it is you know anybody can participate there's no there's no um limits on that
but to see someone do be a medical doctor and also do bug bounty is pretty pretty mind-blowing
um so i'm wondering you know which one of those did you have interest in first and how did you you know
hop how did you simultaneously become very good at both of these things uh thanks you make me a little
bit tired there but um so to start with i think most hackers start when they're young it's it's it's the
the state of mind of like how does this work how to find the boundaries of this thing that that i'm
using if it's a computer game or some software at school so yeah it all started when i was really
young say 12 years old 13 years old when you start building websites or stuff bringing around figuring
out how internet works so i can't say i was first doctor and then a hacker no i think i was starting
real young there and i was developing websites and trying to understand how search engine optimizations
work um but if you have to ask me now guys what am i i will tell you i'm a doctor and then the hacking
thing that is something that came into my life about six years ago so before that time um i did med school
and during med school you have to earn some money because it's expensive you have to live on your own
in some big cities so that's when i started to build websites e-commerce spain startups so i was
responsible for some big auctioning website in the netland some big crowds so i learned from the
full stack developer perspective how to handle a lot of data uh pii data and how to do it a little bit
secure it was all php at the time so that's the challenge but still you learn a lot and um after
that uh i went uh went to work as a street doctor two days a week two days a week startups and then at
one moment i became a gp and that is a special trading of three years just like searching you need
six years as a gp three years in the land and they forbid me to do any sidekicks any any external
uh jobs because they say we pay your training so we want you to focus on it which is okay but a
hacker never stopped thinking as a hacker so a moment in the middle of my trainings i went to
to this um and i can say this group where all the uh all the doctors come together that they are in the
training and my supervisor was there as well and i said like hey is there a possibility that i could do
some variation of chess of chess matches online and if i win them then i might earn a prize it's not
like a guaranteed income and is that is that an obstinative sport actually and then we're like yeah
yeah internet sports that's all but it exists and some sort of chess they say yeah it's some sort of
chess so they gave me permission to do that and that was actually good by this so as soon as i saw on the
national tv some some young guy flerben uh is his name um shout out to forbin if he listens to the
podcast i'm not sure i've never met him in person and flerben was a book barbie in there and on the
national television he he mentioned like yeah yeah some people say uh but boundaries is hard but i earned
10k a weekend for finding books and i was like this guy so young how does he do that so right that was
the moment for me to introduce this to my supervisors and they said yeah let's give it a ride so that's
when it all started so so you know at this time you're you're in training for this for this um for
being a gp and you're you're not allowed to do side gigs but you figure out a way to make this side gig
uh you know a game uh a gamble you know a risk maybe um that has some monetary incentive all right
thinking like a hacker i love it dude um and and i just i wonder i wonder this um i wonder why you
decided to go down the route of medicine when you were clearly passionate about hacking and tinkering
and computer stuff for this whole duration as well right like typically what what most people will do
most people have have a hard enough time coming up with one thing that they're passionate about
um and and really going ham at that but you you identified you know you went the medical
route and the in the hacking route so what what what made you do that instead of just picking it and
sticking with it or picking you know medicine and sticking with that yeah so the honest answer is
um i was 17 years old and i was almost done with the last year in high school so that's the moment
where you go to different university to have a look around so i went to this introduction course on
artificial intelligence actually and i went there with one of my best friends and who uh and later
on ended up ended up at open ai as one of their first employees super proud of him super proud of him
so but um i went with him there and and i sat down in this big big theater and where all the students
come together and then the person in front of the theater started the introduction and said i'm so
happy this year of the 400 interested people four females sign up and this was a moment of crisis to
me it was like okay wait john you're quite good in computers you're not really interested in girls
but you know i might now might sign up for a world list which are only males and that was a problem at
the time these days it's it's less of a thing and that's that's super good yeah but i'm an old guy i'm
37 so back in the day say uh 18 years ago this was a problem so this was when i went back to the
drawing board and i was like okay if i want to live in a world with only guys they will become my best
friends and i will have a great time but i might prefer a more diverse world to to to work in for the
less yeah for the upcoming 40 years and so i started thinking about what was the most interesting
thing in high school stuff that i can't really understand and i would love to learn more about
because this is the moment in life that i can do that um besides computers and hacking and ai and
that sort of stuff i figured out biology is is the thing i had such a good teacher at the time that
it was so inspiring it was one of those those people you meet in life you everyone got a few of
them but this biology teacher um made me decide to do med school and i was quite lucky since you have to
sign up for med school you do say interviews and um it was a lottery at the time so i had to be lucky but
i was placed in in some university in amsterdam and start doing that and it was the best choice maybe
in my young youth because there's so much not only about biology but also about ethics about
communication about uh what matters in life and till this day i'm i'm super grateful that i can do this
work because it shows you how short life is how important it is to enjoy every good minute of it
but also help others out and and share your your luck share your insights and and just try to make
the best of it so yeah that that's a little bit of the background of that that that makes sense i mean
i i definitely felt that draw as well just as i don't know that i've talked about this on the pod before
but um you know back when i was in college and they up until i guess two years um past when you
start college in the u.s you can still sort of change in and go to a different route and um even
though i was really into like computer science and and hacking stuff in college um there i was a part of
a leadership program and the some of the most of the other people in the leadership program were med students
and so they were they were talking to me and my grades were really good particularly in chemistry
um and they were like justin you know a a a like very programmatic thinking computer science guy with
uh you know really good grades in chemistry would make a really killer med school application and i'm
like i sat there for a second and i was like man i would love to help people you know i would love to
be able to to you know be a part of saving people's life or or um you know getting giving people their
health back and i was i was close man i was very close to going down that route so i definitely
when i when i see you on the scene i'm like this is what this is what could have been potentially
you could still become maybe one i'm not sure in your country out of works but in med school when i
was there there were also people of 30 plus uh 40 plus even there uh it's cost a little bit more money
but it's a possibility and i'm sure you you will be a great doctor and with you there's plenty of
money hunters actually that think like doctors but they're not aware that they do since what what what
you guys do what we do as big money hunters we do recon well this doctor where you're sitting in front
of is also doing a return on you and it's not going to pull a fuss on you uh on thousand threats and
draw withdraw all your blood and check it for everything no because you will end up with too much false
positives or collapsing patients just like a server that is crashing because of doing so much recon
and so you pinpoint you do the specific nuclei templates on this human body and then you get
some signal back and then you start figuring out what's going on and you're connecting the dots that's
what bookbound hunters do connecting dots and finding risk groups and in other words uh certain types of
services uh that are running trying to figure out systemic problems that exist in
all different humans yeah that's what we do as well as doctors systemic issues as we look for um
sandbox chrome instances making screenshots and then break it out of that doctors do the same
we are thinking like oh wait a minute this disease looks like that disease and it exists everywhere so
we need to poke into those sandboxes of the human body and see what's going on so there's so many
similarities i'm sure we if we go through a lot of bug bounty and swara into doctors and uh that will
be great we'll be a really that'd be pretty cool and i think i think there's a lot about bug bounty that
can feel pretty like i don't know like green hat right like you're just in it for the money and in some
scenarios bug bounty hunters are notoriously like that and i think it's refreshing to see your take on on
on bug bounty combined with you know this whole ethics piece as well because i know that that plays
a big part with you um you know in your in your perception of the situation um from a doctor's
perspective right um you know you you have taken an oath to try to care for these patients and and in a
similar way i know you're applying a lot of that that technical um stuff to the medicine space trying to
protect the patients trying to protect the doctors and that sort of thing um and and i think you know
there's there's power in in the bug bounty world as well you know being able to find and exploit these
vulnerabilities and you want to use that for for positive means to try to make the world safer and
uh and and care for the people in it yeah it's a part i forgot in the um during the training of
becoming a gp one of the main reasons for also trying to put money thing is um it's a thing you actually
just uh described i'm trained as a doctor to see if some treatment or some tablets or some injection
has more benefits than a risk so i only want to to give you well good treatments and don't cause you
harm and i'm not trained to assess computer systems as a doctor but i prescribe them non-stop i give you
your e-learning as i send forms to you i invite you to my portals i connect systems and so i'm not
trained to that and i have to trust the blue eyes of all those people doing a great job on putting
certificates on all those applications and infrastructure uh the proof is in the pudding and
i want to deceive myself if it's really working any best school to to to go to is so badly since there
is the place where you learn actually what happens what what what is the bugs of tomorrow what are the
bugs of today and what to look for so i don't say uh certificates and and isos and whatever is is not
good no it's part of your your your way to to defend you to defend yourself but the last resort is
bug bounties and yeah you need to be able to think out of the box poke from different directions
and um i think pen testing is limited often by scope and bug bounties still a little bit limited by
scope but more and more you the scopes are widening up and that that is perfect because then you can
connect the dots again think like a real hacker and see how this patient or a doctor is available actually
or the other weak groups we have and there's good money so my disclosure i'm always honest about that
i earned 95 of my money with money so only five percent is with being a doctor and stuff like that
and it's not to remember i tell people to show us no it's just my conflicts of interest so i've got a big
interest in in uh also pushing the bodies but i think for a good cause in healthcare it's it's almost
non-existing well it enlighten me a little bit about how this works in european countries because in the
u.s like doctors normally make a pretty good amount of money um it's one of the higher paying things yeah
and i think that's probably a lot because of the stupid stupid system we have over here where everything
in healthcare is ridiculously inflated right yeah um and and not to say that doctors shouldn't make a
lot of money i think they should because they're doing a big service but i think there's there's
also this aspect where i believe in european countries it's a little bit different where being
like a doctor is perceived more as like a as a as a public service sort of thing um yeah yeah sort of
it it most doctors in the airlines work for the the public health as we say so it's you pay you're
forced to to pay for insurance healthcare insurance that's my law thing you need to do and then you
can also access this healthcare and um doctors aren't good no no no no no no misunderstandings about
that but to give a figure it's like if you're a well-earning doctor it's 100k max and maybe there
are exceptions there but it's so it's still a lot of money but for working five days a week being
vulnerable to all different types of lawsuits and um having to be always on top of stuff and and don't
make mistakes that's that's putting yourself at risk too you know you're dealing with a lot of sick
people you know you're gonna get you can get sick like yeah yeah i imagine so dude that must have been
that must have been terrifying so yeah that that definitely makes sense and um yeah that that uh that
uh it makes sense that you would be out earning that in bug bounty a lot because uh the way that
i've seen it you've been you've been really crushing it um and let's uh let's go ahead and and pivot into
that arena now and i want to pick your brain on um you know your approach to bug bounty programs and that
sort of thing i also want to swing back around to some of how the way um the the way that you approach
some of this health related stuff in bug bounty as well you know making sure you're keeping your body
energized and and how you've been able to continue for such a long amount of time and bug bounty um
with high performance with that but let's let's jump over to the the um hacking stuff uh real quick
hey guys our sponsor project discovery has dropped a new tool in collaboration with google's own mandian
team called tld finder okay picture the sub finder but for top level domains need i say any more check it out
okay so we can talk about the fact that amazon is your primary program um and you've been pretty
much exclusively hacking on amazon for the past what six years five six years yeah really my initial idea
was to get rich quickly on amazon from scroll.am you can still go to this website i think it's still
online i hope my ssl works and if you go there you see an animating gist of how the site used to work
and what i did is i created some front end some lockdown back-end services that um misused in the
end the api of the amazon app and created some pinterest look on amazon so no ui distractions just
you can enter something boom you saw the products so that's when i thought like okay if i do this put
referral links on them i get rich easily because i get this affiliate thing 10 percent of everything that
this is small right in the next days this failed miserably because after four days i was banned
from the affiliate program on amazon but during yeah because yeah you should um and that's their
content on your website and not create content that is solely their content that was one of the real
things uh okay can happen i learned a lot i learned a lot about javascript frameworks and i would love that
micro services and stuff like that and scale it up in such a way that it does not burn a lot of money
but during that time i had to detect the android app of amazon and while doing that i found some
endpoint that was vulnerable to reflected xss and by today that's still the only amazon report that is
this close or medium i think so if you google it you can find it there's some really really fancy payload
with uh uh uh uh ts fuck is i think the name of the payload generator um yeah but um i found some bugs
i emailed them like hey there's an xss there um you've met me so you might be able to unbend me but
okay i understand it's in your personal condition so fair game but you need to fix this back so they
replied back thank you and bye and then it was silent for one year and then suddenly some guy
uh emailed me from the uh amazon security department how one it was one of the founders of the bug bounty
program of amazon and he was like jonathan do you want to become part of some experiment of us as
experiments now tell me what what type of experience yeah we want to create a group that might see the
trust and you're could you could be one of them and i love that name by the way like yeah it's so
dramatic it's like uh okay sure it's brilliant um yeah i love the mice and stuff like yeah this makes
sense if i go to the bar and in a bar and i tell them girl hey i'm jonathan i'm part of nights in the
trust i'm in my for finding books on the website better um so i said yes and that was the moment that i
started reporting books to them earning points and with those points gift cards so so so you were
i guess i didn't know this you were actually one of the preliminary people one of the first people to
be a part of amazon's bug bounty programs and was that was that something they were just running
privately at that point were they running it through hacker one were they like how is that working
big crowd yeah about crowd yeah so nice so that's where i started and uh yeah trying to find more
exercise and all the owls dot 10 bucks uh learning a lot of stuff and that's the moment where at some
point i had 100 joints and with 100 points you earned the certificate and oh snap okay here we go and
this certificate there's something really important i received it i was really proud i opened up the box
and i let me try to find it i got it somewhere behind you go see if you can find it yeah yeah because
there's something fun there yeah i found it nice so
there was a moment i put it in some plastic yeah that i received this thing and have a look at the logo
yeah yeah but if you look closely it's number two it's not number one so i was like who's this number one
guy number two what is this and that was the moment i started doing some some also ends on the internet
having a look around putting it on twitter and on linkedin and i found out there's a guy named
is the channel oh snap no way or one and i was like holy who is this guy what did he do so i got in touch
with him uh we had a immediately a great son like oh no you found this bug i also found i duped you there
and um but but what we discovered that only maybe one percent of the books we found we duped each other
but the 99 we did not so somehow we did different things there so we had some say six seven months where
we raised each other in the charts and then he taught me then i taught him and then he taught me and then
i thought and at one moment we figured out it might be more fun if we collab here and
and just join forces since we all we both do a different thing but we might uh have unfinished bugs
that we can finish for each other and so that that's how all how it all started and and and so
at this point i mean you've connected with with zshano that's great right and uh and so i'm wondering
here like what is you've only had your experience with just the amazon program right like you haven't
been poking around on other bug bounty programs so i mean is that is that i've you did you once you
started getting money out of it like where you're like okay maybe i should look around at this other
bug bounty thing and start going to these other programs or were you always just so locked into
amazon um at the time i was more busy with discovering new techniques and and amazon was helping me with
that but it was also more so if you look on my medium blog you'll see disclosures about ikea yeah it's all
different sort of yeah yeah that's right and that that was not about money it was also it was primarily
about learning new stuff and also uh um just discovering how it all worked the response on
this question the amazon in in the beginning that was all earning points so say the first six months
that was um so you were just doing it for fun yeah it was fun but i got gift boxes with with kindles and
at one point i got invited to to to defcon so that was the the first big prize i got there so uh yeah
i went there with my brother i booked a hotel room got an email back from the amazon team please book a
better hotel room and send the invoice again so i booked a better house there and and that feels nice
yeah it felt like a celebrity so i went to not stay guys with my little brother there and uh had a great
time with this call and hang around with the amazon team which was super small it was how why and some
other people we bunker and um yeah that that's when i also start doing more and also look around a
little bit so i had some message maybe a few bucks sure but my focus was amazon all the time because the
scope is so big and so complex yeah so that's kind of what i want to double click into a little bit
more as well as like you know i think there are very few programs on which it's feasible for you to
spend six years and still be finding bugs out the wazoo i mean you guys found over around 100 bugs
together you and zeshano at this last event which is unbelievable and um and so i mean do you think
that the biggest thing that amazon has going in its favor for that sort of engagement is the fact that
the scope is just so massive and you're constantly finding new applications or is it the speed at which
they're putting code or the interactions with the researchers what what is amazon doing that has been
able to keep your attention for six years they have a realistic scope in my opinion so their attack service
is quite big they understand that their attack service is quite big one of their um goals are is to to
be aware of the new bugs as soon as possible so that's why they have good inter good interactions
with me as a researcher i know their weak spots so i monitor for the weak spots i know what they find
important with the stuff they don't find important and yeah it's it's a it's a good program to me because
um it's so complex we're in one of the biggest companies in the world all digital with tons of employees
tons of talented people trying new innovations and with every innovation there's some risk of
something going wrong and that's where we jump in as bug bounty hunters to make them aware of the risks
and um yeah there's how it never stops how are you how are you aware of this innovation are you
monitoring for like are you watching them in the news do you have like monitoring set up at the specific
application level for new code being pushed or does it just make itself apparent to you because you're
living in that ecosystem yeah yeah you just need to be in the ecosystem and sometimes order a product
it's just like if you want to hack on netflix you should watch netflix movies and if you want to
hack on amazon you should order every once in a while some products so do you yeah do you use amazon i mean
like is that is that something that you use often okay yeah yeah it's important to use the product
yeah do you do you um do you deal with fatigue on the same target like like where you just don't really
want to look at these types of requests anymore or like anything like that or is it is it pretty fresh
um long term no because i take passes so for example after the last live hack event i took a pass off now
i think for a week and some more days so that's really important to me because i also have a lot of
other responsibilities and so that's just recover time if you run a marathon you should recover from this
marathon there are only a few that keep running those marathons but i'm not part of that um i
collab a lot so it's not money i chase it's not the points i chase it's the fun i chase and the excitement
of finding new types of bugs or learn and stuff so you don't get fatigue if you learn something new
even though you're focusing on the right things yeah and if you don't find bugs but you learned
something new then you still have some achievement there and yes and that's maybe one of the take
homes i want to share in your podcast don't depend too much on that money it there are some people who
do it full-time which i'm really looking up to and i i oh that's amazing that you can do that but from
my perspective i got four of three different four different other jobs and that's also part of my
personality income three or four different other jobs oh my gosh jonathan but that that also makes
it easier that if once yeah thing collapsed or or you got too much fatigue from it then you slow down
on that one and and try to figure out with the other jobs or the other stuff you do it could be a sport
could be some sidekick you do the fan of things stuff and other company and they're starting their
own startups at one point or their own products i think that's that's really smart to do because if
you're doing book boundaries for six years full-time i'm not sure if i could do that i don't think i do
so so for you the the reason you've been able to do this so long in a performant way is because you
are not focusing on the nitty-gritty pieces aspects of it and when you get tired you're taking breaks
and you're not putting stress on yourself to perform in the bug bounty world yeah you're just chasing the
fun aspect of it right is that is that accurate yeah that's accurate and i was super lucky though
that i had some wild cards for the first amazon uh like hacky type which was a virtual one during
go of it and i managed to win that one so yeah then out of nothing your first event you win this mph
thing and they are like oh this was the top prize i could win okay that that's good so i don't have to
stress anymore so yeah that was like that you feel a little bit more secure in your in your position
in that that world as well that's good some some zed shano got the first the first little certificate
but jonathan bowman you know got the got the uh mvh with all the prizes also i think this one is uh
it is also zishano is one so we during those events we we call that fully i think i might just
have some more points on the first life action because i found some chain that we popped and he
sure he helped me out to to to do but i had some some more points so yeah i can say if you look at
that from that perspective i might be more mgh but from my from my perspective yes he's he's like similar
you guys you guys have very a very legendary collaboration set up in place and and that's kind
of what i want to stick to next is like you know how transparently are you guys sharing all of the
techniques and stuff because at the end of the day there's a lot of money on the line here yeah and i
know for sure that you have come up with a technique that that you know didn't take any input from him
and and vice versa and and then you guys have to decide okay you know if i give this to zed shano or if
i give this to bowman dr bowman then you know there's going to be some vulnerabilities that they
find that i won't be able to just get and report myself so i mean what does that trade-off look like
for you and and um how have you managed that over the past six years of collaboration yeah well we do a
lot of research together so there's no there's no no problem there if you share stuff no and it's also
it's super fancy what we do so it's not like super high technical complex things no i sometimes go
a little bit more deeper in in some new new techniques and at the same time he he also goes
deep every once in a while and if i tell him i will pause for a month i'm very happy if he reports
about finding some chain i created together with him and i'm and sometimes we share it a little bit
it's it's just sinking in with each other like hey how does that feel yeah it feels well okay you
go on from this thing i'll focus on this other like hack event um yeah have a good one and then by
the end of the week he made a shit ton of good money yeah i'm at this life hack event super proud on
some some some some some high uh ctss back that took me 10 days to develop and and not with for the
money but just for the for the for the sense well and that's okay yeah you should i think that that is
the thing and if you're thinking enough with each other and both are on the same page on that and then
you yeah then that stuff is not then the money will come too i mean at the end of the day you're you're
you're you're performing better together and you're collaborating and you are sharing that knowledge
and um you know i think you said in an interview with hacker one that i watched in in prep for this
podcast that a lot of the advancements that have been made in the medical industry have been made
because of relentless sharing of information and and trying to get that information out to everyone
so that people can save lives and help people live more quality lives yeah and i think you know you've
applied something similar here with with this collaboration where you guys share and that just
continues to compound and compound and compound um yeah i think that that's just a good summary and and
the best thing is that relationships should go over any virtual internet points or money or whatever
and that's just in a relationship with with with a partner in in real life uh yeah although i speak with
sean maybe as much as with renee my girlfriend that's always a funny thing yeah sometimes it's the first
person i speak to and by the end of the day the last person i speak to already is already sleeping but
um and and yeah you share a lot of stuff in life and i don't have to worry and that's maybe a good
other take home thing is try to find a bug bounty partner a lot of people i think and try to build up a
trust relation with with the other person sink in and if you feel like hey this feels uncomfortable
just bring it up and say hey what do you think about that yeah should we communication yes communication
and also in my work as a doctor that's that's main the main thing is communication about if you do stuff
stuff wrong if i did something wrong yeah i tell people i did i messed up i did it with a good good
reason but it was not good uh yeah let's fix it so have there have there been you know in in this
commitment to communication and you say hey does this feel good with you does this feel good with
you have there been times where you guys have said no that doesn't feel good and no that doesn't feel
good and and you know you guys have a disagreement that you have to resolve at no more at length no
really it's been it's been pretty smooth yeah yeah but that that that is some luck in life that you run
into people that are not complicated or not in in in the game for fame or money no of course it takes
the bills so yeah i yeah of course that's the thing but by the end of the day you yeah but as you said
you're more together if you if you look for the long perspectives and um it also does not burn you out
so it yeah there's a lot of benefits there lots of lots of pros to that so so swinging back around
to the amazon program itself one of the things you had here in the list uh in the doc is is that amazon
one of the things that makes amazon a great program is they have consistent payouts for certain bugs
bug types um can you talk a little bit about what that why you really like that and how that makes
amazon an amazing program so for all the people who work for program listening to your podcast the
one of the the the key things you need to try to achieve is consistency and that's also in hard
part like how do you apply cvss how do you rate certain bugs um how do you deal with some xss that
someone already reported but you got a new report where there's a payload that does different stuff
there or approved account takeovers or stuff like that um and that's something that you can do as a
program where you give the same answer multiple times in a row about certain bug types and be predictable
um take feedback from researchers like hey this might be odds that this payout is so much lower or
how do you feel about that or would it make sense if we change this uh would that be more interesting to
you and that conversation if it keeps going and the leadership is there also continuing the previous
leaderships um that makes it a program consistent and less stressful as a researcher because the last
thing we like to see is that one day you get say 1k then 3k then 4k then 1k and then you start asking
yourself like what's the difference is the way it feels like our our work is discredited as well like
sometimes you can be really proud of a bug and then you're like ah wow you really don't see that and
and that's disappointing yeah so it said that that is the perspective you need from a bug bounty hunter
you you feel some yeah you want the reward and you want to be a consistent reward because otherwise you
might doubt like hey is it less good or yeah that's that's really important i think that's probably one
of i i i have to say i think that's probably one of the reasons that amazon has been able to keep so
many anchor hackers like you and zinchano is that they they have their their thing and they stick to
it and they pay the bugs and that sort of thing and you can become very consistent then and and you
can really understand the threat model of an organization and of an application very thoroughly
and that just feels it just clicks right you know when you when you finally when you get these bugs
paid and they're paid the same way time and time again you can really feel like you've got mastery
of a specific set of a program or a set of applications yeah you understand way better what
they find important to them and um also do you understand more and more how to report certain
stuff or what what is necessary for them to see in a report that makes them like okay this this needs
to get priority because by the end of the day we don't want um we we want the proper ctss or rating for a
buck because that helps also in getting stuff fixed well there's more ethical perspective but i think it's
an important one um so sometimes i'm i'm fighting some some downgrading by of a buck not only because
well it earns maybe a little bit more money but to be sure that's on the top of their list to get fixed
and that everyone got a true understanding of the truth of the real impacts um and and last thing about
that is that um it's super important with big companies like amazon's but also all the other big
big companies on the stock market is that you you tend to have people moving around the company
after three four years so there's a thing that if you work for a certain big company you need to have
some career path and that's a hard thing because we as spook money hunters have to deal with different
phases different teams new new leadership etc and that's something that amazon achieved quite well
is to to keep the the mindset the same as it was six years ago the same sort of people are working in
their leadership positions and and what what i observe now doing that balance for a while is that you see
programs changing so so fast into great programs turning into programs with a lot of problems and
it might be money because less budget might be changing of people working for the teams so
try to get some some permanent positions seniors yeah people will understand our position as a researcher
but also understand the internal problems and then then you have a great problem yeah i think that's super
important even even in just the you know year and some change that i've been running this podcast
year and a half i've i've said some great stuff about programs and then you know come back a year
later and it's like completely different experience because of turnover and because of changes within the
organization so that consistency i think is huge from a from a people level as well and it's something
that i think extends beyond just the realm of security as well we i think it's sort of a problem with
tech in general right now is that there's so much turnover and so much job hopping to climb the ladder and
that sort of thing where people just need to pay more money and and you know or have a consistent
schedule to go up so that these people don't have to jump around from job to job to job and relearn a
new system every like two or three years exactly yeah yeah it's it's it's intense man um i think with
that i think we'll move into some of the more technical aspects uh i'm very excited that you have agreed to
um uh release some of the information about this server-side template injection vulnerability
on file sender um with us on the pod today so um thanks for for for doing that can you talk a little
bit about that bug and um how you found it and how it can be exploited so file sender is quite interesting
piece of software it's used for the last well maybe 15 years i think it's it's really old when i was
in in university doing that school i used it and it's used in the netherlands and all university
and other uh colleges to send around files because uh we had we did not have file send of a um we
transfer and the other uh um solutions at the time so university figured out let's open source a tool
ourselves and we called file sender so you can find it on gina it's a quite interesting tool since well you
can connect um some um some sso some logging thing so students can log in and then people can upload
stuff and you can send someone else a link or an email with the the content and it works quite well
um but in the recent years they also um added some extra services behind it so s3 is supported now so
that's it that's good for storage uh aws additional layers of complexity as well though yeah yeah through
that and and i um had good contacts with in the cybers of the infosec uh community of the universities in
the netherlands we got some sort of one internet service provider called surf amazing people working
there and they reached out to me like hey john we are trying we are thinking of rolling out a full
new version of file center file center tree and we did a lot of pen tests already we think it's quite
secure but can you have a final look at it and quite being quite busy with the uh with the life
hack events i had it somewhere on my list but i to be honest forgot forgot about it so i got a reminder
from one of the people working there and like john you should have a look really do it do it so i was
like okay let's do that so i asked them like hey do you have amazing that you fit this in dude amazing
that you make this happen i don't understand continue sorry yeah and so i was like uh can you spin up a
machine where it's running so i can first do some black box tax thing before i i dive deep into the source
code and what we do as bug bounty hunters we look for earn all stuff first because that um yeah has the
highest impact so what types of stuff can we find and quite quickly i figured out there were certain
error messages and those error messages uh came up within the url some base 64 coding and i decoded that
and i figured out hey there's some templating stuff going on there is i saw some template codes that's
and then i tried to think like why did i do that and the reason for that was they have different
university different logos different temp of designs so in emails they want to give different uh logos for
example um and also to um yeah to to expose like where's the the actual um base url and what's the base
or something like that and i could see that i could manipulate manipulate the error message enough
and then i just start looking in the code in one of your previous podcasts it's like where's the
request was was one of the main main changing is saying yeah where's the request game yeah yeah i love
that yeah where's the error came from and so that was the thing i tried to do so i just literally
download the zip file from get a get up uh impact it open it up mcs code and just did console shift f
and search all the files for um the the error message actually that was appearing so after a few
clicks i figured out where is the loop that tries to replace those um those templates uh attacks in error
messages figured out where it was so no complex debuggers with php storm or something no just just
looking in the code and i thought there was also a conflict uh a conflict uh template variable that
was used for the um for the paths the server paths actually so where could i download where where should
it write temporary files or something like that the next moment you do after when you find that you
immediately look for what other conflict variables are existing and then you figure out oh wait a
minute my sql database user and password so i tried to do that and i saw the username and password and
i was like oops isn't that good oh and that's not good dude how how far are you into this assessment
like is this like you just seven minutes checked it out for oh my god so it's just getting an error
and i'm like hey base64 as soon as we see base64 it's like extreme out on the skin we understand like
there's something going on there and we need to get you a cream and in this situation we need to look
at you just go why should you use base64 though so that was the first first thing and then uh yeah it
was quite easy to figure out and um this new version also has s3 support um so i saw that i could dump
the scripts and the access key of s3 buckets uh giving full access to the to the system so i reported
back to them like hey there's a problem with your version three uh you might need to have a double look
extra look at that and then a few hours later i was like but if it's in the latest version why is it not
in the currently used version so i looked into the source code and i you got this thing gets blamed
where you can see how old he committed i love that and that's this command was 10 years old and i was
like oh oh this thing is already hanging around for 10 years and oh man so i looked into the production
version of the one used by my university and i figured out that they were vulnerable i could just
see the s3 key and access uh token and that's all the stuff so i tried to log in at only book at just
the proof impact yes i could access it so that was uh quite a complex problem since this software is used
in a lot of places in especially um education but also some some healthcare organizations are using it
some big governmental organizations are using it uh and then you have to start to do the
responsible disclosure and they did an amazing job since it's all open source things so it's all like
people doing this and as volunteers are you are you working with the file sender team directly at this
point are you working with that collective of okay nice yeah yeah and luckily enough they were together
with some conference in paris so so they set up a call quite quickly i got them through to understand
where the books are are existing then they try to figure out how to help patch this that was quite
hard because it's a templating thing so it might break a lot um so they start creating patches um
they start monitoring if the books were abused that because it might be a zero day already discovered by
someone else sure and and then the part two of the thumbs of the thumb yeah it's fun for me as a big
bunny and turn up yeah i don't think they would describe that day as fun no no no no no no no i think
that's also the hardest part is being a doctor sometimes you feel so excited finding this rare
disease but you have to understand at the same time there's someone in front of you not happy so
right right you're not happy with excitement on moments where that this couple of years um
part two of the excitement comes was the moment they start developing the fix this git commit book
was published yeah and super interesting from the truffle sec right was that i think so yeah so long
story short every fork in a repo is uh even if the fork is hidden the commits might be also hidden but if
you know the hash of the commit some piece of it that is unique they can still view it somehow that it is
security through obscurity um so i figured out like hey would be fun if they start trying to patch this bug
and commit on the public repo and um lo and behold that's what happened so so that's what i did so i
reached out to uh loop in and uh to triple themselves like hey i want to try this tool how to do that
and looping being a great talent that the hacker already figured out pipelines and stuff so he helped me a
little bit there and uh i run this script on some some little linux box for i think two hours three
hours in total and i found the commits they made to patch this thing so dude so i had to reach out back
to them again it's like hey dudes be aware that at this moment a lot of gith commits of github commits are
being uh scraped and if it's not known dispatch there is a risk that this patch is found by someone
and also the zero day is exposed or one day whatever you're called so then we're like oh no you again
no get out of here
that's great but the way how to handle it is also that is academics that's why i work one day a week in
academics is is there also find this and are also like oh this is cool how does that work so well
that's good i'm glad that they that they appreciate it because it it is it is pretty cool stuff um and i
was looking at you know when you sent me over this this 10 year old commit or whatever i was kind of
looking at the way that they patched it and stuff and it's a little bit of an odd thing that they're
doing it looks like here right because essentially the way that this vulnerability was working if i
understand correctly was um you know there would be an exception page that would be generated and then
then you would pass a base64 encoded you know exception string or something like that into that
page and then that would get concatenated with a template and then that template would be rendered
right um but they're still doing it looks like it seems like they've moved that user controlled
portion of that input into uh some some um something different so it's not getting concatenated into the
template there they've associated it with the session but it still looks like they're dynamically
rendering templates themselves right like like in in it it's different from actually taking a template
and uh you know rendering it it's dynamically creating a template then that you will then render which i
think is just a little bit of a weird way of doing things um so i i wonder i wonder if there are more
server-side template injection bugs on this on the software because it i mean like you said it's pretty
widely used i believe um so i think there could be more more things there do you have any plans to
continue looking at it further oh yeah for sure yeah yeah yeah yeah i i tried to break it i was not
able to break the patch but if one of your listeners is please reach out with our teams um and to the search
uh behind files and i think it's also the main repos if you open it up there there's ways to
to get in touch with the uh the owners uh and if you got struggles always feel free also to reach out
to me but um thousand little org it is i think file center or yeah that's the way you should go so um
and then contact so yeah if someone finds something there something there there might be still a way to do
this but um i'm not experienced enough i think to do that so that's help the research world help out
academics uh it's a little funky yeah and you don't earn big money that's the thing yeah you earn some
you know the thing of doing good for human mankind and maybe some stickers some t-shirts whatever maybe
some stickers or t-shirts yeah that's good um are you you're planning on doing the blog post as well
in conjunction with this pod right you're gonna drop that or is it gonna be okay so so we'll have
a we'll have a blog post down in the description i'll uh i'll call that out now um when we release
this episode um and then we'll we'll probably put the the poc somewhere up here on the screen or
something like that as well so that you guys can understand um exactly what's happening but um i was
reading through some of your other bugs as well jonathan and i actually see you know a a a trend
of server-side template injection which is just really a weak bug for me like i've only ever found
server-side template injection like once or twice um and and so what um what are you doing that is
making you find these server-side template injections i know that in one of your articles you mentioned a
custom burp scanning profile that helps with that um but what are you just spraying the payloads around
or thinking about it from a templating perspective what's going on there um i try to use the burp
active scanner in such a way that it only scans for useful stuff and i think you can there's a lot of
trainings around on how to use burp uh and how to use all the different options but um i think the most
important part is how to use the active scanner in such a way that is useful and there are a few steps
i always take first i look at the target i try to figure out what coding language is behind it
sometimes there are multiple ones it's like a reverse proxy somewhere on an endpoint and sometimes one
and especially with the old coding language is like pearl and the ancient ones there you want to be sure
that it's part of your active scan and often uh but by the enders turn them off the active scanner
because they get your bands on akamai or whatever uh this is too noisy um and they forget to turn it
on or if they turn it on they only turn on the xss or uh server interaction types of stuff but if you
toggle on the the template injections uh the per code injection and and that's what it's called in the in
the active scan then you might end up with bugs that other people missed out and so there's there's an
interesting book does on rce i found on owls one of the biggest food companies in the world nowadays
and the only way i could find that was because i had my burp configured to also scan for pearl code
injections and they get some some payload that does um yeah this does from sleep or proof it there is
code injection to go in back you need to start coding pearl which i can't do myself dude it's so so
terrible so terrible so so now you you need to figure out which chad cpt your old friends uh our old
friends uh to uh to get something useful and then savage yeah and then yeah you end up with good stuff
but and that is a way another way is um try to understand how their uh how the templates are
rendered so for certain targets amazon for example i know exactly what types of strings they use for
templates and for a lot of other targets i also know and you can discover by looking at uh not
properly rendered pages for example and that's you need to be lucky there so look in your sitemap look
for for the the the generic templates types of uh you write the template codes yeah angle brackets and
that sort of thing yeah and then figure out okay those are the the the the the angle brackets they
use okay this is an example of what actually also get runners a proper variable uh and then you might
put that in your work list for um for your own justin sketch so that's that's the way to go i know i
noticed also in this write-up that you did with um a hold usa that you first brute force for parameters
on this specific endpoint and then you did the did the scan and and that scan uncovered the the pearl
injection is that i mean is that something that you you have a part of your flow pretty often is
identifying each individual endpoint and then brute forcing parameters on those endpoints correct
yep yeah the challenge for us as bug money hunters is to discover intersectionality and um
um query string parameters form uh parameters that are not mentioned in the javascript not mentioned
anywhere but are doing something on the code that's where that's where you want to look because other
people miss that out and so yeah you need to have some flow where are you are you using paramminer for
that or are you mostly just using intruder like you are in this in this article i've got a hate
relationship with paramminer hit a lot of things so i turn it on as everyone and i turn it off after
20 seconds and then i turn it on again and then i turn it off because it never stops right if someone
can fix a version of paramminer that actually behaves and doesn't go wrong and everything that will be
super helpful or what do you mean by go rogue are you talking about how like it adds like cash cash
poisoning or like canaries or whatever to all the different requests or what do you what are you
talking about i might need to read the manual yes i might tick the wrong boxes there um but
often for me it slows down it hangs so that's that's maybe the thing that on amazon i would not
recommend you to use paraminder for example will give you a lot of headaches um gotcha and so what
you're looking for in those scenarios is just something maybe that that has a little bit more
um feedback so you can see whether it's it's slowing down or whether it's not slowing down or that sort
of thing and uh and then you are hoping you know to be able to stop it and start it pretty easily is
that the main the main problem you see with that right now see what your what are the tasks but that's
the same with the active scanner of burp you should rule out any path with gpcs with images for example or
fonts or css there's not much there so and if you don't do that it will try to do a pro code injection
on the css file yeah which makes no sense right and so yeah you need to limit it happily to to be
effective and this is book post on uh i'll i showed that you can also use intruder if you got a feeling
this page must be vulnerable just go manually i i almost ultimate nothing of what i do i just look
carefully about what's going on what's happening so it's good so let's say you identify a cool
funky looking request you send it to a repeater or whatever you're playing around with it do you
pretty much instantly send it to intruder as well and and launch off a a uh and then let that run for
a little while look at the responses that are different and then keep playing with it that's
the that's the flow yeah yeah and they have at one moment six different intruders and you keep
refreshing them and you keep looking at them and then yeah yeah you're lost on your screen and then
you think like okay got 20 repeater taps and now four five six seven eight windows of intruder help
oh man yeah there definitely needs to be some organization stuff that that is a little bit different
in that in that area yeah that's pretty cool though um yeah so i think server-side template injection is
definitely a a tricky one for me i definitely i definitely want to grow in that area i don't
have a good flow right now for using a scanner that would alert to that sort of thing um mostly the way
that i'm i'm i should be doing it but i'm not is just putting these you know curly brackets or angle
brackets or whatever into a part of the like xss payloads that i'm using and spraying across the
the website is that something you're doing as well are you mostly relying on the scanner to detect that
no that totally makes sense yeah yeah yeah and and and then you still have the challenge of a lot of
template engines are custom stuff like file center is a great example where you need to know the specific
way they write their template uh tags uh and if you if you don't use it in a proper way or with a
variable that's not existing then you might miss a miss the the injection so yeah if you're able to
try to figure out some real working uh uh templates of template and code blocks that makes sense yeah so
so pivoting a little bit you know you mentioned before that one of the early things you did earlier
with um amazon was breaking apart the android mobile app and kind of diving into that a little
bit understanding how the apis work to build this this website or whatever that was going to make you
a millionaire um and and uh and i think you've you've done a pretty good job as well just looking
it's like talking to you at the live hack events and seeing the kind of bugs you're finding of looking
at that peripheral scope of android and ios and i think a lot of people go down the android out uh route
but not as many people go down the ios route um so can you talk about your methodology uh uh with ios
apps and how you're you're approaching that um to attack these these bigger organizations yeah so it's
really important i think as a big bounty hunter to have a an ipad that is jailbroken and to have an
android that you can use to easily man in the middle because um if it's too big of a hassle to
men in the middle all those apps you don't do it or you lose too much time if it's super easy to do
then you for example in the live hack event you get the new scope you see okay we've got six apps there
we've got some websites okay let's install those apps right now on my ipad and on my android wait for
five minutes and then come back and then just start trying to man in the middle then and see what's
traffic so my methodology is uh i got an ipad that i jail break with pill rain bill rain is one of those
jailbreak tools and there's still an ipad available that you can jailbreak with that tool that also
updates to some of the latest ios versions i think it's the tablet ipad 7 so have a good look on the
pill rain website and see which models are still supported and if the model also supports one of
the latest ios versions because that's a problem you need to have recent versions um but the last time
i checked was three four months ago and it was still working well um so that's the thing and i got a spare
android phone pixel thing that i rooted but also uh with android you can easily do use uh apk
a metm epk man in the middle it's on github so sometimes i just patch the ap key and then i
install it but i also think here it's important to to have those devices separate from your own device
because otherwise you end up with your personal phones full with strange ads or yeah yeah keep up your
own uh your own security so have those different devices there also really helps to open them up
and update just all those apps and see which apps can be updated so you get some signal back from like
hey there's something new this is this is really interesting uh this apk mitm um tool that you
mentioned here i hadn't actually seen this before i'd seen something similar with uh called objection
which allows you to patch apks and then hook in yeah uh via frida scripts and stuff like that but
this actually seems like it's oriented specifically more towards um like getting rid of uh sir pinning
and that sort of thing and it just goes for that so it's like a one shot let me see if this works
yeah it does great and then if not obviously i'm gonna have to go down the custom route yeah yeah and
that's also sometimes i do so then i go um uh give it a try with frida or objection and try to patch it
myself there's only one time i was not able to disable the man in the middle and that was some
heavily obfuscated app from some government somewhere that that had if i had to patch it i had to patch
it on system call level in ios and my good old friend chat gpt was hallucinating too much to help
me out there so i got stuck in a lot of rabbit holes and then i figured out okay i might need to wait
uh for all the people to figure out how to do this properly but most of the time uh apk i mean
man in the middle thing works or objection and then the fun starts then you need to to use the app
and just see what's going on and is there any hidden functionality do you need to are you able to
to to get some perks if you are an artist or if you sell stuff or whatever you can get the app
configured in general yeah yeah that makes sense so that's most of my time i spend on is understanding
how an application works or where are the edge cases the the uh i really like what you said here
is get some framework in your brain to for both excuse me for both android and ios where it reduces
friction to get to the man in the middle point right because a lot of the value for us as as web
hackers is looking at these apis and what kind of different apis the mobile app is using as compared
to the the web right um and so if you have a a system in place okay you know we download the apk we
are on the device we pull it off with adb we run you know mitm apk or whatever the name of the thing is
to patch it and then we we send it along and if it works great if it doesn't fine you know just having
that in place and not having to think about that whole thing and the same same flow for ios um opens
up scope for you when it's easy and when you when it's not you you can go a different route or you
can choose to double click in exactly and and and one other important advice is have two of those
tablets because one day one will break and you have a lot of stress so i got two ipads i got two pixels
and that removes all the stress for me that if something is is bricked because it's all jail
breaks it's all that's you try to update them and then see if you're if pill rain still works
and you don't want to endure this moments of truth no you want to be like okay i got my backup here
it's working if i break this one i still got my back up there so yeah that's also an important lesson
i learned it i imagine that helps as well for like cross user testing like you don't have to go log out
of the app on this one and log into it on that one and like all right now i'm just trying to use two
sessions on one ipad you know it's like yeah geez excellent yeah i think it's worth the investment on
a on a uh a refurbished ipad that's all refurbished those those models so it costs nothing you can buy
them on amazon.com buy them on amazon this was not altered by amazon.com please click my affiliate
give up your dream jonathan don't you're never going to become an amazon affiliate oh my gosh
no um but you can yeah it costs nothing and it saves you if it saves you two hours of headaches or stress
then you get your money back very much worth it very much worth it um i'm looking through some of
these other things here on list and i think next place you've got two more cool bugs that i want to
go through this this chain of uh of three bugs in in the health care dutch health care system stuff and
i and that also sort of leads us down the path of um why the threat model changes with the different
industries that you're in right uh and i think a lot of times in the bug bounty world we are very much
used to um poc or gtfo sort of things and but i think this this medium article that you wrote up on
people being able to send executable files through a a portal that um was meant for sending patient
information can have tremendous amount of impact so can you talk to us a little bit about that assessment
and the vulnerabilities you chained together for that one yeah so um i tried to bring back everything
i learned from big money in healthcare just to to improve and make make the industry more mature and
on the infosex uh uh thing and um one day i decided to see how feasible ransomware attack would look like
in this so being a gp myself um i'm quite vulnerable i got a lot of patient data i got a lot of
colleagues running around a lot of clients and so i started with having a look at one of the biggest
insurance companies in the netherlands i'm i'm also insured by them for my uh legal problems and at the
time they don't did they did not have any responsible disclosure policies um but they are like
like yeah an organization founded by doctors so i expected them to be doctor friendly ethical doctor
friendly yeah so there's one problem there is that they also sell insurances for cyber uh cyber risk
and ransomware attacks where they give a guaranteed payout for ransomware uh attacks of 100k plus so if you
insure yourself or if you own the bucks then uh if you got ransomware and they will pay the ransomware
group and which is a problem because in my industry there's no money so if you run to where you get
a box of candies with not tasteful candies because that's all we have in our you know practice there
is not there's no big money floating around there and um you you've brought those uh netherlands candies
to the live hacking events before it's like what is it like the black licorice or something like that
yeah yeah yeah i i don't like that uh good that you remembered uh-huh you're more fond of the strong
bars i guess i am this joke that those are very good those approved yeah there you go no so so i figured
out like hey they're creating a big risk to my industry and they'll seriously do it because people
request them to sell those insurances so it's a complicated problem but my perspective must
uh smell good but also like they're the first name targets i would like to hack as a ransomware group
because if i hack them i know exactly who's insured for which amount of money and that will be well my
dream come true because then i can pinpoint my attacks so so you're hacking the insurance provider to
understand okay this company this company this company this company all have insurance policies at
100 grand so i need to go pop that one and that one and that one and that one there you go so that
was the moment when i when i discovered that like oh wait this might be a thing then i start poking more
into their infrastructure as i'm a client but i had to be super careful because i did not have permission
no responsible disclosure the thing there just so i was more doing this to uh do good for society being
some sort of journalist i'm publishing about security issues so i've got some protection in the
landlands but i need to be careful so um and i reached out my mom my mom is a psychologist and
i asked her like are you also in church with them and she was like yeah i am so at that moment i had
two accounts on my left screen i have my mom active on the right screen myself so i was able to safely
hide or my own account from my mom's and it's well and it's the fan and whatever happens with with lawyers
and judges and i could at least say i i did try to only impact myself and i did to try to do that
that trend in the nls you're quite quite safe if you do that um so that that's why i opened up burp see how
it all works and then i figured out hey there's some inbox with all your pdf documents that request has
some integer of your membership number and i could replace my member of my mom's membership number with mine
and that way i could feel all the cells that were part of my profile including the insurance policy term sheet
so yeah so i reached out to them and they they handled this really well so they patched this back within
hours or a few days and they reached out to me to discuss how they can improve their overall security
by the end of a few weeks they also published a responsible disclosure and had to to convince
leadership there that it's a good idea to get transparency and i think yogurt once put that
on twitter transparency is trust and yeah that is one of the most important parts i think in our society
in our book money programs in um but also from a customer perspective i want to know is something
went wrong and how you handled it and and if you learn something from it's all good and so i try to to
convince them also to to let me share the story and after some debate they agreed on that and so that's
the the the proper route to to go it's really good to enforce change you know by that by bringing to
the public and that sort of thing and i think especially in these very high uh data sensitivity
in industries it's super important to have at minimum a responsible disclosure programs yeah otherwise
otherwise how are how are people gonna be able to report stuff and dude it's so common i've actually
found almost an identical bug to the one in your in your write-up here within the past month on a
healthcare thing in the us where it's literally just up in the url bar you know member id equals you
know numeric idor and it's like ah this is really not good yeah yeah and there's no way we're the only
one seeing this right like there's there are definitely other people that look up there and
say if i'm member id one two three then somebody else is going to be member id one two four and
that's not good how does it when when you were recording this was it part of a bug bounty program
or no it wasn't a part of a bug bounty program it was something that i use and and so i went in there
and i i was i was like i opened up this pdf file i have exported it so that i could you know do something
with it and uh you know in the pdf export of course there's like a you know they like slash pdf renderer
whatever and and just put in the id and it generates the output and i i looked at it i'm like
oh no so i sent an email and i i um to their support team because they didn't have any security contacts
and then i called the company and said hey i just sent through an email and they're like uh we don't
really know what to do with this and i'm like that's fine you know it's not it's not you just can you
pass it to somebody in it please and uh with him they fixed it within 24 hours which was amazing
yeah um but yeah i mean they didn't know no email back no response no nothing just just just yeah and
and that that's a super important thing we need to push more for as a society to do all the people
creating like this uh the laws all the people in government working for governments try to see what
you can do to get every every piece of infrastructure that holds data of citizens of your country
that they have some way of that there's some way to reach out to this infrastructure to report security
books to but also try to see if you can enforce or support transparency because um enforcing stuff is
not good because people find ways around but if you if you share the reason why we we need to be
transparent about stuff then you also create more awareness on all levels like hey we might need to
bend at something every once in a while hey we might need to check something for the race before we deploy
it or that that will protect us from people who want to do harm and in the healthcare industry
where it's where it's our biggest threat at the moment they are super smart they've got really big
budgets and i i i bet they already fixed my paraminer book and they were like oh yeah we have mixed that
already because of their budget but yeah we got we got so much um stuff exposed on the internet and
i mean if it's hard to reach out to to to companies like you have to go through all the hoops yeah that
that's uh that's that's work to do and maybe not that'll work but um um yeah yeah we need to ask
somebody from the policy side you know yeah i think i think one of the things that i haven't seen a ton
of is in like pretty much only i've seen this from from jack cable here in the us and you over over there
in the netherlands as well is trying to get involved with the policy creation and trying to influence that
at at a big scale um i think that's really important work and will make it easier for us to do
these sort of things in the future and continue to go move forward um with you know reporting these bugs
and getting them addressed in a way that's and also get you rewarded for your assessment of time
yeah yeah because people aren't just gonna you know people aren't gonna do it just for free
forever you know and and so there should actually be some some additional monetary incentive i think as
well yeah i fully agree on that yeah yeah so so that was the first hit so we now know in the
netherlands everyone was insured we should uh uh hazard for or pinpoint our target uh or attack some
the second book i found was um in the netherlands as a doctor you need to have some subscription with
a person that will handle all your complaints so if you're not happy with me you can find some
complaining against me and then this independent person will try to mediate and try to figure out
how could we hear from it so it's not like a legal procedure it's more like get stuff fixed and gets
done in a in a proper quickie way but most doctors use their private details for that because they want
to be aware of any any problems as soon as possible and we receive this stuff just with the ordinary old
male so um that was my next target it's a super smallish organization two people working there but
they have a lot of sensitive data all the the doctors but also the psychiatrists working in prisons and
stuff like that they hold all the data and they had a subbook that if you signed up for uh a new profile
everyone could sign up you ended your registration number as a doctor they call a big number but it's um
it's just an integer code that's public you can find it everywhere i need to share it also with you
if you ask me it's the way you can check if i'm actually a doctor if you uh ended that in your new
sign up processing they return an error like sorry you already have a profile please log in but if you
look in burp you saw in the response the full account details they haven't put it in the response so
take home message here always check your burp for any responses they might not render it on the
website but it's there in that in a response so also they handled it pretty pretty well and quickly
and they patched it but at that point we had all the private data of all the doctors also the doctors
were having this really good insurance policy we have to coverage for a lot of money if you're
interested in the internet and you can't do it in the internet and you can't do it in the internet
and you can't do it in the internet and you can't do it in the internet and you can't do it in the
internet and you can't do it in the internet and you can't do it in the internet and you can't do it
in the internet and you can't do it in the internet and you can't do it in the internet
and you can't do it in the internet and you can't do it in the internet and you can't do it in the internet
so like we use us as gps sure and i got access to a few of them and one of my gp buddies Bart
is also sometimes hacking so i reached out to Bart and i was like hey dude do you've got any
which systems could you test for me he was like yeah i got access to two of them and said yeah good
so we have coverage about all of all the systems so i explained him the thing and he was like yeah i
can try that for you so you want to upload an executable instead of a picture of the xema i've seen
oh yeah it makes sense so all day all our clients can send messages through some portal and can upload
and picture so it's easy for me to ask like ah it's nothing or yeah at this screen so that moment me and
Bart start trying to upload executables and most of them got blocked because there are some some men in
the middle party that is um um is doing a lot of those portals but one of them did not block it so then
we discovered like oh we could just upload an executable and for me as a doctor it the executable
is displayed in my inbox of a windows desktop application all custom java i think it's really
ancient legacy software um and i could just click it and it opened up the executable and we did a proof
concept with some setup dot action nothing fancy no ransomware there but we proved that we could just
send those executables to specific doctors you can sign up as a ransomware group to any doctor you want
to there's no no real uh no no user what we call privilege required that will be non or low maybe but
i would say oh my gosh and uh yeah so that was rce there um yeah user interaction required but still good
same so so i mean essentially what you did is something that we talk about you know on the pod
from time to time here is is building out that full threat model vision that that full attack vector
vision right you started with enumerating all of the um you know doctors and that have these insurance
policies and and then you figure out a way to actually get that payload through to the doctor in
a way that's reasonable and i mean that that this is beautiful this is really beautiful because at the
end of the day it makes it so much clearer for um the the people that are not in this this bug bounty
world this or even people that are in the security world but not in like the full let me pock out this
whole thing world um how how easy it is to put these pieces together and achieve some really crazy impact
um and i mean this is exactly how a a malicious actor would go about this right so this is also the
the end of the day for programs i think if you want to be a great program just say the scope is our
customer data figure a way out how to hit it and no fishing because that's too easy but think out of
the box and to do that the only way to do it is we got proper policies in countries where you are not
limited by other companies suing you because you found a back in their systems no we need to create a way
that we technically create those chains because it's not only amazing stories but it is actually
the way it works in real life with the with the threat models we have to work with so i yeah i think
this is really good i think this is something that a lot of programs could really do better on some some
programs will put treasure maps out there and say like hey we care about this we care about that
but i think incentivizing full fledge attack methodology is really cool so saying like hey
if you can provide some way to show a vulnerability show distribution and exploitation of this vulnerability
in mass then we'll award additional bounties for that or we'll award bonuses for that or we'll have a
set you know tier or whatever that you they reach to if you're able to provide me with a reasonable attack
vector uh that chains things together and makes this attack that somebody could very easily implement
exactly and and a mistake i see programs now making is to put third party code or stuff like that or
enterprise software out of scope if you do that you lose big talent uh because there are some researchers
focused on that finding your your zero data your enterprise software that holds all the sensitive data you
can think of so start doing that take responsibility for the stuff you implement in your company it's
your decision to use this enterprise software and be aware of any bugs and if it's a zero day you want
to know and if it's a one day you might also want to know and it's the change that that will be the
ones that impress leadership and in the end also protect your customers or your clients whatever yeah please
so a lot of a lot of times this these these enterprise softwares i think they were actually
just discussing this last week on the um on the asset note podcast uh surfacing security about how
these these third-party vendors are um really becoming the shadow it of this generation and and
oftentimes the weakest links are are not this this code that are part of the main application but these
little vendors that they're like ah we kind of need this tool but we don't like fully vet it we just
kind of plop it in on the system and then time and time again you've seen uh shubs and the whole
asset note crew just destroy those pieces of software and it's absolutely detrimental we need so
many people like shubs in this team shubs is one of the most impressive hackers i've met in my
hacking career super grateful to work together sometimes with him and what he learns me is that
there are so many weak spots in software that is used everywhere but you need to invest heavily on
that and you need to to to go deep really deep and if we don't let that be part of the bug bounty game
or uh our trap models because we're it's enterprise or it's for party then you lose out on the most
important bugs you might have and um yeah yeah i'm i'm super happy that he is investing on that and and
uh yeah and and doing great research it's very important i think um all right i want to be
respectful of your time dr bowman but i do have to ask uh a couple more questions about this okay so
moving away from the the technical stuff and bringing it back around to something that i'm sort of
tangentially um passionate about with regards to bug bounty is how we as bug bounty hunters can take care of
our bodies and take care of our minds uh as we're doing this very addicting very uh you know hunched
over at our desk for hours sort of thing right um so as as the uh official doctor of the bug bounty world
tell us what we need to know about how to maintain our posture how to keep our brains functioning um you
know in these super long hacking sessions um what what do you have for us there yeah it all starts
with vegetables sir you know um why do you just pull out a carrot as a bug bounty hunter the most
important part is to have a golden clade with carrots on it it's the only way to have a constant uh
constant way of finding bugs now uh all jokes aside have absolutely healthy habits that's the most
important thing and habits you create them by doing stuff periodically a few times a week and if you
do that long enough it becomes a habit and if it's healthy then it's good so um for myself i've got the
healthy habit of starting every other day lifting weights it's super boring um in the book when i see
and i see quite a few our listeners around us you know yeah i'm just the boring one we're looking like
that's hard like oh dude how do you do that i'm not dedicated enough to do this yeah but still
i create a healthy habit of going and doing that and i'm doing this for a long while i can't think
of a situation where i'm not doing it that's also a struggle with life hacky fans then you're in other
environments and you sometimes don't have the ability to do those healthy habits or you tend to not do
yeah so i try to figure out how to do that um for me for example uh to youtube channels i use often
abroad or mad state and bully juice just easy home gym stuff which you can do without any any extra
you can yeah just do it on a night here out over it i discovered that during covid because all the gyms
clubs now are still using it by today um eating yeah obviously everything you put in your mouth
can be harmful on the other end life is short so you might enjoy it so yeah don't be super strict
in everything find the right balance uh people sometimes ask me like do you drink alcohol well most
most people most of the time i don't i might drink once a month maybe once every three four months
max yeah but that's that's one of the hacks i use to stay sharp and focused um i remember from the
time i was a developer i and if i had some alcohol i thought i was i had the greatest ideas and then i
look back in the color it was horrible the next day so that was a good objective uh observation of uh
uh that it's not working well same with weed i never smoked weed even though i'm from amsterdam
but something called same with with weed i've never smoked sweet in my life um for some people it works
and there's quite a high rate of add or adhd and about many people having yeah so that's often the
reason people use uh weed to get some focus or some some mind states that works for them but also there
are other ways that are more healthy to do so yeah i'm not telling you you're doing wrong but there's
there's different ways to cope with the problem what i i'm not sure if this is your arena because i know
that like posture health and that sort of thing is something that's that's kind of different from
you know general medicine stuff uh it's more in the physical therapist realm but um i i've recently
uh had an injury in my shoulder and um as i went to go talk to a doctor about it you know he was saying
that um from working at a desk you know the shoulders are sort of slunched slunched forward
like this a little bit and um because of that the pectoral muscle is is shortened okay and it's put
and it's pulling the shoulder down right and so one of the things that he he had me do that it's been
amazing for my posture and really helped with my ability to like reach and and swing when i hit a
volleyball is um he's had me take like this ball like a lacrosse ball or like a tennis ball and like
lean my chest up against a wall and push this ball into my chest muscle to loosen up this muscle right
here and that pushes that allows for this muscle to be extended a little bit more and allows for my back
muscles to pull those shoulders back into place oh wow that's amazing and i was like i was like man
this is like this is the kind of stuff i need to know about you know like these hacks to keep keep
the posture you know up straight when you're hunched over the computer normally because i think a lot of
us get so in the zone with bug bounty where we're like not even thinking about you know we're sitting
like sideways and like yeah yeah exactly all the levels i owe stuff um yeah investing yourself and
get a future therapist also maybe once you've got some problems with posture i try to sit in different
positions all the time uh i've heard that that's big is changing the position that you're in not just
not any given position but just changing on a pretty regular basis yeah so that works for me but it might
not work for other people but it works quite well for me and uh in a lot of my jobs i've got to sit
in uh i got to sit down and in my work as a doctor i sit on some strange odd chair that looks like if
you sit on a horse i'm not sure what it works yeah that is but the um like a saddle yeah like a saddle
and that also makes you like sit in all different ways and that works for me um and with with all the
complaints you have um the thing is with muscles it's the it starts with if you have a problem
there you can go to fish therapy get some massage and then the problem is gone for a few hours and
then comes back to me to learn how to stretch the muscle you need to learn after that how to train the
muscle and if you improve the condition of all your muscles you are less prone to to catch another pain or
uh problem so that's why you also should start doing sports even though you don't have any problems at
the moment just to stay in the same song and then we're getting older and older and older and when
getting older stuff got worn out and that's part of life the only thing you can do is start training and
and keep training it's important to be consistent about it too like you said because for a really long
time i was doing i was in the gym you know five days a week and lifting and that sort of thing and
then you know i've recently had uh a a child in the family and uh and when you have that things get a
little bit difficult you don't get as much flexibility in life and and so i stopped going to the gym um and
stopped lifting as regularly and uh you know it wasn't six months after that happened that i i threw out
this arm playing volleyball and dislocated my shoulder and had this whole this whole problem
start that i've i've been clawing my way back now for for one month you know or longer than a month
actually just trying to get this shoulder back in a position where i can use it so um it's it's you know
it's a little bit of a tough lesson for me that even if you are um you know lifting on a pretty
regular basis if you just stop for just six months that's enough for the degradation to to occur
and for some some injury to to happen yeah yeah so so if your habits have just like the ipads have
two of those ipads you can jailbreak also have this this this thing uh a backup a backup plan like the
youtube videos and then you make the agreement yourself okay for conco digital gym i'll do this
30 minute workout just home and so keep moving and yeah it's a great idea that's a great idea dr
moment all right thank you so much for joining us man i i i appreciate it so many different areas
of wisdom across collaboration across hacking across health um really a pleasure thanks for coming on the
pod man thank you for the invite and uh yeah if anyone finds good ducks uh hope to hear that on your
podcast if you find books on file sender let them know they need more eyes and uh yeah happy to uh to to
meet the people in the in the discord i think i'm not sure if i joined already but i'll have another
round so feel free to perfect thank you so much that's the pod peace